what's going on what up this is our
first this is the story of the GoPro
video indeed I hope to be doing this
every weekend with you guys we're in Des
Moines Iowa and we're heading down to a
place called Culture Kings
[Music]
oh wait a second but I'll show you
something different
yeah
well never mind
um so where what happened
it is I can't see anything I can't
believe I'm in charge of the camera you
wanted me to drive ladies and gentlemen
we are here we are at Culture Kings this
looks like a really nice store actually
Des Moines Iowa let me just give you his
logo real quick Culture Kings and we're
gonna take a step in right now see what
the deal is
how you doing man
how are you
yo he's got shatter backwards all three
of them all the ones you don't have
a 10
10 and a half is you how are you man
Jacob brother nice to meet you Brad yeah
I like those shoes by the way he's got
the Phantom Travis Scott's and I love it
this is Brad man glad to coach King's
Des Moines yeah [__] yeah man this is a
great story you got some really you got
some good already right off the bat some
good stuff in here no this is a legit a
legit sneaker store yeah I gotta look at
the Grails of course I have those
prestos I love them the probably the
most comfy shoe that I own oh yeah I got
the blacks I got the blacks oh I just
got these washed blacks but I literally
they're literally sitting at the hotel
we got these last weekend Jacob's been
looking around and he sees a bunch of
stuff that he likes indeed and I'm gonna
get you something you have to be able to
answer
a question though I'm gonna name a band
for you okay and you're gonna have to be
able to give me three songs of that band
sang
okay okay I know it's gonna be an old
rock band yep because it's the question
you always ask me yeah and last time you
did this I didn't do well no but it also
wasn't for shoes
okay so that might be a different
incentive okay well listen
good luck okay please name
oh that I can do I was really hoping I
was really hoping you were gonna say
Beetle six Beetle songs okay come
together let it be Eleanor Rigby
um
ah did I say come together yeah come
together let it be Eleanor Rigby by the
way what help
um he wrote an album I'm trying to name
I know I have two more I'll give you
another two minutes to name two Beatles
songs I can't believe Eleanor Rigby was
one of the ones I like that song that's
a good song Oh The Beatles song um I'm
missing some really big ones that's why
I'm trying to okay wow are you feeling
the pressure in your [__] right now
I'm feeling it everywhere I think I'm
actually sweating yeah yeah
ha ha ha ha
ha
suck is that you're not you know you
don't get it and then you're gonna watch
me buy something dude I have I know I
can name them I just like the biggest
song two more Here Comes the Sun I can't
believe that's one of the ones you
picked out and uh five it's five where
do you have for time I got 40 seconds 40
seconds left
this is crazy
imagine that's John Lennon yeah dude no
that doesn't count come on that doesn't
count you were so cocky
I know this too you almost [__]
dropped the mic on that one imagine no
that's not it pick a microphone John
Lennon it's like 20 20 seconds
I'm missing massive ones oh dude oh
massive ones yeah yeah
do you want me to give you I did pick
some of the weirdest songs yeah you
picked all Abby Road songs yeah yeah
she's a weird wait I got eight seconds
we have eight seconds all right you four
three two one completely blank how about
Hey Jude dude no Hey Jude
about Helter Skelter how about I want to
hold your hands how about any uh [__]
um
there were so many there was one more I
saw her standing there old songs yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
uh While My Guitar Gently yeah dude what
a great pull see I'm pulling a bunch of
[__] out of my hat now I guess we'll
have fun watching me pick something yeah
up to you all right all right you wanna
tell them what you want or not one
anything it was more like you lost
that's true and by you losing I won
we're gonna get some of those nice nice
Shadows yeah I love them it's like it's
gonna be a good shoe for you because
these are gonna be easy for you to wear
but you're still gonna get some good
credit for yeah Hey listen why don't you
tell everybody what you're walking out
with
nada
zilcho yep alert bone up on your Beatles
music son I named four so fast I was
like oh [__] ring me up dude and I
couldn't even get the last two it's like
trying to hit the last cup in beer pong
you know what I'm saying I can never do
that like yeah I I can't clutch up at
the end do you know what
um I want you to know that I've never
played beer pong because when I was in
college we just drank like men all right
ring me up
isn't that a young person thing to do go
long walks
you have to walk off a lunch because
that's not something young people have
to do I did walk off our breakfast
that's what I'm saying
but it's it's about exercise
that's that's that that is am I wrong
it's true but it's not really true
I just want to show you what kind of old
man [__] he goes through on a daily
basis so we went to a little market
because he's like I need to get
something to eat before we work out so
it was a nice little tiny Market but
this is what he got I I haven't even
seen yet so let's do it together first
things first he's got some raw honey and
yes he does just squirt this in his
mouth he doesn't eat it with anything
he just squirts it in his mouth he's
like what the [__] is he like Yogi Bear
what's happening here and then
got some blackberries blackberries are
delicious
the only water not the only water but he
loves this water Mountain Valley but I
don't understand he's like oh yeah I
can't drink out of a plastic bottle or
an aluminum can because it'll make me
sick
whatever this this is the old man [__]
right here okay I'm gonna just poke into
the bag and you're gonna see what I see
those are just two whole avocados
again he's not gonna put anything on
these he's going to pop it open and
shove it in his mouth that's it so
rate Joshua's Market trip on a scale of
zero to one because it's pretty bad we
are back from our shoe store at Escapade
I skip that's good
whatever it is
we went to a shoe store uh we're heading
to the gym right now I'm gonna get a
quick workout in and then we are going
to shower get ready and head to our
shows give your impersonation of the
face I do when I work out
I hear like uh
do I bend over like that no I would
depends on what set you're doing I guess
uh what are you doing today
chesticles
I don't know what I'm doing I think I'm
gonna do back and shoulders just do legs
getting on a plane tomorrow dude no
don't play your family uh we're gonna
prop this up so we can film a couple
things
as long as there's nobody else in you
are you guys vlogger uh not really kinda
what's up yeah we do a little bit
that was so cute kid just thought we
were like vloggers on YouTube and he
just literally [__] himself
I don't know what a vlogger is this a
vlogger is this probably people who
literally just Vlog yourself oh I didn't
bring one another extra down all right
all right well we're gonna pop it up
[Music]
foreign
you got good hair man holy [__] good God
huh
[Music]
okay
come on
can we enjoy ready for the show yes sir
hold up bro
how y'all doing I said good to see you
again good to see you
hold on good to see you
all right here we are
uh you wanna let me know where the food
is I'll go ahead and get it so you don't
have to go back up yeah
all right so we're in the green room now
and I'm gonna go get our food for us we
go on stage in 30 minutes and some green
rooms are
bigger than others and some are
greener and some are
you know yeah not a screen here we are
we'll talk to you guys later